[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages donner du sens à l'actualité
choisir les meilleurs experts pour vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
crises que le monde traverse voilà notre
objectif tous les soirs à 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat et justement c'est un gros
plan sur la Chine que je vous propose ce
soir pour la première fois depuis 60 ans
la population du pays a baissé l'an
dernier la croissance est également la
plus faible depuis 1976 c'est un coup
d'arrêt est-ce pour autant le premier
signe d'un déclin chinois ce sera notre
débat d'actu et puis vous le savez on
choisit souvent de prendre du recul
d'attendre quelques jours après un
événement ou des annonces officielles
pour les analyser le 6 janvier dernier
Emmanuel Macron dévoilait son plan santé
il s'agit notamment de répondre à des
soignants en ville ou à l'hôpital des
soignants en détresse
on est devenu maltraitant on ne peut pas
voir tous les patients qui demandent à
nous voir on peut pas leur offrir la
médecine qu'ils attendent d'avoir on ne
peut pas leur obtenir des rendez-vous en
temps et en heure compatibles avec de la
médecine de qualité on est incapable de
salariés à une secrétaire un assistant
qui pourrait nous permettre de faire
cette médecine de qualité et donc le
soir quand on rentre chez nous mais on
le vit très mal recrutement d'infirmiers
d'infirmières d'assistant d'assistante
médico meilleure rémunération des heures
de nuit fin de la tarification à
l'activité mise en place d'un tandem
médecin administratif à la tête des
établissements hospitaliers ont
décortique le plan Macron dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord la Chine qui
paye la facture économique après trois
ans d'une politique zéro covid aussi
absurde que brutal Sandra Cerqueira
c'est un tournant historique la Chine
pays le plus peuplé de la planète a vu
sa population déclinée en 2022 du jamais
vu depuis 60 ans avec 9,56 millions de
naissances l'an dernier ce n'est plus
suffisant pour compenser les 10,41
millions de décès enregistrés dans un
pays rattrapé par le vieillissement dans
les rues à Pékin ou à Shanghai les
habitants considèrent que la baisse de
la population est inévitable au vu des
alertes qui pèsent sur la croissance
chinoise il y a beaucoup de pression
pour avoir des enfants mais qui ose
avoir des enfants aujourd'hui le taux de
chômage est si élevé le covid à tout
détruit il n'y a rien à faire l'année
prochaine nous aurons à nouveau une
croissance en baisse les personnes nées
dans les années 2000 atteignent tout
juste la vingtaine et beaucoup de jeunes
ne veulent pas avoir d'enfants la Chine
attendait une croissance de 5,5% en 2022
finalement elle n'attendra que 3% sur
l'ensemble de l'année
un chiffre décevant pour Pékin qui
enregistre son plus faible taux de
croissance depuis 40 ans en cause trois
ans de politique zéro covid avec des
confinements au moindre cas positif et
des tests de dépistage obligatoire pour
accéder au lieu public des mesures
strictes qui ont été levées récemment
mais ont entraîné des fermetures d'usine
et perturber la production les
exportations de la Chine ont connu fin
2022 leur plus gros plongeon depuis le
début de la pandémie moins 9,9% sur un
an à quoi s'ajoute une consommation des
Chinois dans le rouge et des
investissements en replis
nous sommes confrontés à un
environnement international complexe et
difficile la demande intérieure se
contracte l'offre subit des chocs et les
attentes s'affaiblissent une reprise
économique significative n'est pas
encore solidement établi cette année la
Chine devrait voir son PIB croître de
4,3% selon les prévisions de la Banque
mondiale
toutefois revu à la baisse le mois
dernier
démographie croissance économique la
Chine subit un coup d'arrêt est-ce le
début du déclin en débat avec
Jean-François Huchet bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes économiste spécialisé économie
de l'Asie et de la Chine en particulier
et président de l'Institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
Mario haltman bonsoir bienvenue
sinologue spécialiste de la dissidence
chinoise présidente de l'association
Solidarité Chine j'accueille également
Baptiste falves bonsoir bienvenue
rédacteur en chef à France 24
journalistes à asialiste et ancien
correspondant en Chine vous avez été en
poste là-bas pendant 7 ans et midi
zappalski bonsoir ici bienvenue à vous
spécialiste en communication politique
et éditorialiste pour sens public cette
semaine je commence avec je reprends ce
chiffre un chute de la démographie on
l'a vu une première depuis 60 ans - 850
000 personnes en 2022 Jean-François
Huchet comment ça s'explique
il y a plein de facteurs évidemment mais
les premiers qui vous viennent en tête
alors c'est principalement la baisse de
la naissance et la baisse de la
fécondité qui a commencé il y a déjà
assez longtemps
on rappelait en juste avant cette
émission qu'il y a eu un pic de
fécondité à la fin des années 1960 avec
près de
6,53 enfants par femme ce qui était
voyez des familles très nombreuses Mao
avait effectivement pousser les familles
chinoises à faire des enfants ils
pensaient que c'était bon pour la
puissance de de la Chine
et donc cette croissance de la
population en fait elle remonte même
avant les années 60 puisque dès la fin
de la guerre civile on a une croissance
à partir de 49 on a une croissance très
rapide de la population chinoise donc il
y a eu un déclin régulier depuis un
déclin régulier avec quelques petits
soubresauts au début des années 80 mais
globalement aujourd'hui on est un taux
de fécondité
en forme par femme et ça s'accélère et
donc aujourd'hui on arrive à ce point
voyez de bascule vers quelque chose
qu'on avait anticipé les scénarios des
Nations Unies avaient déjà anticipé
effectivement cette baisse de la de la
population chinoise avec toutes les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur les
différentes classes d'âge de la
population sur l'économie mais aussi de
manière générale sur sur des questions
de plus de sociétés sur les retraites on
a envie de dire à la Chine bon on va
bienvenue au avec le club des pays
qui doivent traiter justement de ces
questions en fait ce qui se passe je
termine là-dessus la Chine est en train
de devenir vieille avant d'être devenu
vraiment riche et c'est ça que ça c'est
intéressant et on y reviendra évidemment
sur ces conséquences économiques Mario
smack qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
annonce officielle ce sont des chiffres
officiels du bureau national des
statistiques chinois peut-on croire les
statistiques officielles chinoises ça
c'est toujours une question que
par principe on peut jamais croire les
statistiques officielles chinoises mais
je pense que là c'est quand même assez
réaliste ça doit pas être trop loin de
la vérité
j'ajouterai à ce que je viens de dire
Jean-François Huchet que il y a quand
même eu 35 ans de politique de l'enfant
unique donc on peut pas être surpris
qu'après 35 ans de limitation des
naissances ça finit par avoir un impact
d'autant plus que les paysans qui
préfèrent les garçons ont quand même
pratiqué assez souvent l'infanticide
dans ces des centaines de milliers de
petites filles qui n'ont pas pu grandir
et et aussi des échographies qui
montraient qu'on attendait une fille on
se débarrassait de la fille etc etc donc
il y a soupçonne pas le traumatisme que
ça a provoqué pour des millions de
femmes en Chine mais je suis contente
que vous le disiez que ce soit pas moi
qui le dise parce que je pense que la
société chinoise est polie traumatisée
quoi parce que les anecdotes sont
innombrables le nombre de femmes qui ont
donné leur fille à quelqu'un d'autre
pour pouvoir avoir un fils par exemple
vous imaginez ce que ça donne à la
psyché féminine de se dire ma mère m'a
abandonné parce que j'étais pas assez
bien j'ai vu un documentaire chinois
extraordinaire fait par un jeune chinois
qui a découvert sur le tard qu'il avait
une sœur aînée et il est allé
interviewer sa mère qui a refusé
d'arrêter Decher la terre donc elle est
en train de baiser la terre en lui
répondant et il lui dit et si moi
j'avais été une fille qu'est-ce que tu
aurais fait et elle a répondu sans lever
la tête je t'aurais donné à quelqu'un
d'autre comme ça sèchement
c'est terrible c'est terrible parce que
personne n'a envie de donner son enfant
mais la pression
tradition la famille etc pour que les
femmes accouchent de garçons étaient
terribles Baptiste falvossi Yaya
effectivement là on était on a eu une
première explication qui était
démographique vraiment la natalité mais
il y a il y a des ressorts
psychologiques évidemment c'est
important à mettre en avant il y a une
chose que j'aurais quand même c'est que
c'est un phénomène qui est quand même
asiatique enfin en tout cas Asie
orientale je veux dire aujourd'hui aucun
pays que ce soit la Corée du Sud le
Japon Taïwan la Chine Nathan ce qu'on
appelle le seuil de renouvellement des
générations en Corée ces catastrophique
on a moins d'un enfant par femme
aujourd'hui en Chine on est environ 1,15
après les les derniers chiffres
effectivement il y a des ressorts
psychologiques avoir un enfant en Chine
comme dans beaucoup de pays d'Asie où il
y a une compétitivité énorme que ce soit
chez les parents que ce soit à l'école
pour votre enfant réussissent soit le
meilleur c'est une charge c'est un poids
c'est un poids financier très fort c'est
un poids psychologique et ce phénomène a
peut-être été très même renforcé par la
politique de l'enfant unique
c'est-à-dire qu'en gros pendant des
décennies vous n'aviez qu'un enfant sur
lequel vous misez tous les espoirs du
foyer et je vais le dire de façon un peu
triviale mais il fallait pas se rater en
gros donc on mettait on investissait on
investit toujours massivement sur cet
enfant moi je m'étais beaucoup intéressé
à ce sujet lors d'un premier
assouplissement de la politique de
l'enfant unique je crois que c'était en
2013 et beaucoup de parents me je ne
peux pas me permettre d'avoir un
deuxième enfant il y a les cours de
piano les cours d'anglais les cours du
soir les crèches privées pour l'enfant
soit le meilleur et voilà et donc c'est
vraiment un problème c'est que l'enfant
coûte très très cher alors c'est
intéressant parce que il y a des
témoignages qu'on a récupérés sont des
témoignages
de nos confrères journalistes de de
l'AFP et répondre deux personnes là
qu'on a choisi leur réponse elles sont
presque plus intelligentes que que le
discours officiel chinois voilà pourquoi
les Chinois font moins d'enfoirés ce qui
répond
nous pensons que la pression économique
sur les jeunes est assez élevé surtout
pour ceux qui viennent de l'extérieur de
Pékin et vivent ici c'est déjà difficile
pour ceux d'entre nous qui sont nés dans
les années 80 nous sommes le nombre à
être issus de famille à un seul enfant
il y a beaucoup de pression lorsqu'il
s'agit de prendre soin de ses parents et
d'améliorer sa qualité de vie à l'avenir
si le nombre d'habitants diminue les
faits sera très important sur l'économie
et sur la population active future du
pays
de même pour la retraite et l'assurance
sociale du pays l'impact est énorme avec
de nombreux effets négatifs
est élevé pour avoir un enfant il faut
avoir les moyens si en plus vous avez
une personne âgée à la maison un parent
chez vous avec la pression au travail
c'est très difficile de trouver le temps
et l'énergie pour élever un enfant
Baptiste avec vous parce que en écoutant
le témoignage vous parliez du mariage
c'est quoi c'est une institution en
déclin le mariage complètement
aujourd'hui le nom de mariage est en
déclin depuis 2010 chaque année l'âge
moyen auquel on se marie et ne cesse
d'augmenter aujourd'hui on a un peu plus
de 28 ans pour le premier mariage on
était en 2010 si mes chiffres sont
exactes autour de un peu plus de 25 ans
même pas non non autour de 24 ans 24 ans
près de 25 ans c'est dire c'est dire à
quel point donc cet âge de cesse de
reculer pour toutes sortes de raisons il
y a la pression effectivement de tout ce
qui est matériel quand on se marie en
Chine faut qu'on achète l'appartement la
voiture vous avez un coup de
l'immobilier qui ne cesse de croître
c'est une pression et vous avez aussi
des femmes qui veulent s'affranchir de
cette contrainte du mariage tout
simplement parce que souvent c'est un
peu la double peine pour beaucoup de
chinois c'est à dire qu'elles doivent
gérer une carrière de front dans un
cadre quand même conjugal qui est très
patriarcale s'occupait aussi des enfants
à la maison gérer l'éducation et
aujourd'hui beaucoup de femmes ne
veulent plus
cette double peine et donc ce mari le
plus tard possible ou ne se marie pas du
tout or on ne peut pas ou c'est
quasiment impossible d'un point de vue
social sociétal d'avoir des enfants hors
mariage en Chine donc le mariage il est
aussi pour quelque chose vraiment et je
trouve très intéressant c'est que cette
idée enfin ses évolutions sur la
démographie ça nous donne une image
complètement différente de la Chine et
d'ailleurs les sujets qu'on aborde là
sont le témoin de ça c'est à dire que on
a l'impression que c'était un peu un
tabou parce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sur l'enfant unique les
infanticides qui avaient l'histoire des
mariages des femmes qui veulent un petit
peu s'affranchir un petit peu de cette
vie qu'il est coince le système social
qui va falloir qu'il mettre en place
peut-être on voit en Allemagne que ça
coince aussi pour les bébés puisque les
femmes ne trouvent pas de système pour
garder leurs enfants ça nous donne une
image complètement différente de la
Chine c'est sûr que la Chine s'est
nourrit de la mondialisation sur le plan
économique mais ça ouvre les portes
aussi de cette société qui voit qu'il y
a d'autres exemples qui voit qu'il y a
d'autres modes de vie qui ont envie de
s'affranchir de ce mode de vie très
autoritaire et quelque part ça a ouvert
les vannes sur un changement de société
et de façon de penser vis-à-vis de la
famille du travail et de tous tous les
aspects de la société qui financièrement
peuvent être plus indépendantes qu'à une
époque quand même qu'il y a 20 ans qui
aujourd'hui c'est quand même plus accès
à l'étude gagne mieux leur vie et donc
ceci explique aussi cela Marie Oldman
vous nous avez parlé de la politique de
l'enfant unique j'ai oublié de vous
demander ça a duré combien de temps et
puis peut-être aussi c'est quoi la
politique du régime actuel en la matière
est-ce qu'il y a des voilà est-ce que
c'est liberté vous faites autant
d'enfants que vous voulez même si on a
compris les les freins culturels et
psychologiques c'est il y a une
politique officielle démographique tu
Régis alors c'est intéressant l'histoire
de la démographie chinoise parce que
effectivement dans les années 50 Mao
était obsédé par l'idée que les
Américains risqueraient de balancer une
bombe sur une partie de la population
chinoise et envisager à ces calmements
de perdre 100 millions de Chinois et
donc il disait donc il faut faire la
il faut prévoir quoi de rendre le
remplacement et il a encouragé les
femmes jusqu'à leur donner des la taille
du mérite si elles avaient plus de 9
enfants quand même et il y en a beaucoup
qui travaillaient pour avoir leur
médaille du Mérite après il y a eu la
famine qui a fait quand même 40 millions
de fins morts de faim entre 58 et 62 et
après donc ils se sont à nouveau
rattrapés pour compenser un peu tout ça
le traumatisme de la famille bien sûr et
en 59 je retourne un peu en arrière il y
avait un démographie
comme ça on va avoir une croissance
démographique insupportable qui va faire
peur au monde il pensait déjà à ça et
Mao qu'est-ce qu'il a fait bah il a mis
avec les droitiers il est resté je crois
18 ans dans un camp de travail et c'est
intéressant il est sorti en 1978 il est
allé de trouver donc shopping qui était
en train de faire son retour il lui a
filé ses préconisations et donc shopping
a dit mais quelle bonne idée on de
mettre en place la politique de l'enfant
unique qui a commencé de façon très
ferme en 1980 et quand je dis ferme
c'était d'une violence inouïe une femme
à la campagne qui procrée pour la 2 ou
3e fois pouvez voir sa maison
complètement détruite par les
commissaires du village et ça dure
jusqu'à quand et ça ça dure jusque 2015
c'est en 2015 qu'on lève l'interdiction
de l'enfant unique et on va timidement à
deux enfants et là le gouvernement
chinois se rend compte que ah bah oui
mais deux enfants ça va pas faire la
reproduction et ils sont allés jusqu'à
dire les membres du Parti communiste
chinois doivent d'ici 5 ans avoir fait
trois enfants sinon ils perdent leur
poste donc à nouveau
cette tentation totalitaire c'est pas
une tentation ce fonctionnement
totalitaire c'est moi qui décide c'est
insupportable donc aujourd'hui les
chinois ils en ont plus que ras-le-bol
ils veulent plus faire d'enfant c'est
compréhensible Jean-François vous avez
commencé à l'évoquer mais cette baisse
de la démographie elle a déjà elle aura
des conséquences économiques
majeures il faut bien voir que entre
[Musique]
de ces jeunes actifs qui depuis 2013
sont de moins en moins nombreux et mais
il y a d'autres conséquences qui vont
bien sûr sur les systèmes des retraites
donc je sais pas si bon on en reparlera
tout à l'heure mais le coût quand même
aujourd'hui est estimé à 4% du PIB on
pense que d'ici
2035 2040 ce sera 20% du PIB oui mais
alors et vous l'avez un tout petit peu
évoqué tout à l'heure pour pour d'autres
pays ça a été plutôt une bonne nouvelle
quoi c'est-à-dire le signe que le pays
était arrivé à un niveau de maturité
économique et de richesse là vous dites
c'est trop tôt pour la Chine pourquoi
effectivement Baptiste évoqué tout à
l'heure le cas du Japon et décoré et on
fait des calculs qui montrent bien que
en fait cette ce vieillissement de la
population il intervient beaucoup plus
tôt en Chine et sur un système qui est
quand même déséquilibré en terme de de
personnes plus riches urbanisées et puis
de quand même une masse de population
encore très importante dans les
campagnes qui qui matériellement encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire et donc
il faut financer ses retraites en plus
on a eu cette politique de l'enfant
unique qui fait que il y a une pression
très forte sur un seul enfant pour
souvent
apporter son soutien à quatre
grands-parents donc c'est un c'est une
pression énorme qui pèse sur les enfants
on a même eu des lois dites
confucianistes voté au Parlement pour
dire les enfants il faut vous ayez
rendre visite à vos grands-parents c'est
pas bien il faut respecter la tradition
chinoise en fait on se rend compte que
la Chine va basculer comme beaucoup de
pays vers vous voyez un système de
protection sociale de avec trois
générations sur le même toit et qui est
en train d'évoluer très très rapidement
on a des personnes seules qui se
retrouvent en ville en nombre très
important vous voyez que il y a vraiment
et puis on pourra aborder aussi les
questions du dynamisme
sur l'innovation de l'entrepreneuriat
tout ce qui a fait un peu aussi la
recette du made in China vous voyez tous
ces jeunes qui arrivaient des campagnes
qui allaient travailler dans les usines
qu'on exploitait et bien tout il est en
train d'être remis en cause par cette
évolution démographique c'est une lame
de fond qui est en train de vraiment de
transformer la Chine alors on y
reviendra évidemment sur ces cet effet
sur la croissance que les chiffres de la
croissance sont également beaucoup plus
enfin historiquement faible pour la
Chine on vient d'un peu plus tard mais
là je voudrais ouvrir un chapitre sur la
parce que c'est lié sur la la politique
zéro covid ce coup d'arrêt économique
c'est aussi la conséquence de trois ans
de politique zéro covid alors elle a été
levée 7 décembre alors cette annonce on
a recherché qui l'avait annoncé à quel
niveau de de responsabilité on a trouvé
cette annonce du porte-parole de la
Commission nationale de la santé
regardez
il ne sera plus nécessaire de fournir
des preuves de résultat négatifs aux
tests d'acide nucléiques des codes
sanitaires et des cotes de voyage il n'y
aura plus non plus de contrôle des
personnes qui se déplacent d'une région
à l'autre les personnes ne seront plus
tenues défectuer un contrôle à leur
arrivée dans une autre ville voilà je
propose tout de suite à Quentin calmer
de nous rejoindre sur sur ce plateau
bonsoir Quentin parce que ces mesures
elles deviennent la très concrètes en ce
moment avec le nouvel an lunaire oui
tout à fait je voulais vous montrer des
images elles ont été tournées ce
week-end on le voit dans la région du
Jang sousst à l'est du pays voyez des
millions de personnes qui vont ainsi se
déplacer pour regagner leur famille au
centre du pays effectivement à
l'occasion du nouvel an chinois qui se
tient le 22 janvier des images que l'on
avait plus vues depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire car le pays fonctionnait
effectivement sous cloche la politique
zéro covid a été décidé très rapidement
fin 2019 début 2020 pour protéger le
système de santé chinois très fra avec
une population vieillissante vous
l'évoquez à l'instant mais aussi car on
s'est rendu compte après que le vaccin
chinois et bien c'était révélé peu
efficace cette politique fonctionnait
sur trois principes des confinements dès
la découverte du cas positif des
restrictions de déplacement on le disait
des tests de dépistage généralisé une
politique à l'efficacité toute relative
3 ans après le début de la pandémie la
population dispose d'une faible immunité
car trop isolée et avec des vaccins on
les a donc peu efficace et une
population qui a commencé à se rebeller
contre cette politique zéro covid ça
devient intenable pour le gouvernement
chinois notamment ça commence le 15
novembre tout à fait le point de départ
ce sont des mouvements autour de l'usine
chinoise de Foxconn qui produit des
iPhones ces images elles ont été
publiées sur les réseaux sociaux autour
du 23 novembre alors que s'est-il passé
et bien les autorités ont décidé début
novembre de confiner pendant une semaine
près de 600 000 personnes qui vivent
autour de l'usine après la flambée du
nombre de cas le mouvement de
contestations s'étend alimenter
également par les images des stades au
Qatar Thomas car on voit des spectateurs
qui font la fête dans des stades et ce
sans mesure sanitaires des émeutes
éclatent ainsi dans plusieurs grandes
villes de Chine comme ici à Shanghai le
27 novembre elles sont considérées comme
les plus importantes depuis celle de
Tiananmen en 1989 les manifestants sur
ces vidéos que l'on voit en ce moment là
il scande alors zigging démission et sur
cette même vidéo ils investivent la
police servait le peuple servait le
peuple on voit ses confrontations comme
cela cette politique aura donc aussi un
impact massif sur la croissance vous
l'évoquez déjà un peu passez de 8% en
2021 au moment de la reprise post
première vague du covid a donc 3% en
2022 merci Quentin Marie oldsman il faut
peut-être rappeler parce qu'on va parler
beaucoup des conséquences économiques
mais ce que à quel point cette politique
zéro covid a aussi permis au régime de
j'allais dire fliquer pardon d'être un
peu trivial mais de sur la population
Chine tout à fait on a on est passé du
degré je ne sais pas combien au degré
maximal de la surveillance puisque tout
était enregistré là où vous passiez avec
qui vous aviez mangé ou combien de fois
vous êtes allés à la pharmacie ou au bar
où je sais pas où
on a on n'a jamais vu un système
totalitaire aussi complet et je crois
que ça aussi c'est quelque chose que les
chinois ne supportent absolument plus
enfin personne ne peut supporter ça il
me semble
j'enfonce Huchet
c'est quand même la séquence qu'on qu'on
vient de résumer quand un Calmet et qui
est en cours c'est à cet enchaînement on
peut même remonter au congrès au 20e
congrès avec le le président oxygène
pine qui balaye tout ce qui pouvait
rester de d'opposition enfin c'est une
séquence qui est quand même assez
fascinante où on voit que c'est génie ou
en tout cas on a le sentiment vu il
finit par publier face à la face à sa
population face à oral-ball généralisé
est-ce que vous l'analysez comme ça
alors je pense qu'il y avait déjà des
prémices vous l'avez indiqué dans dans
ce reportage je poste congrès jusqu'au
congrès rien n'était possible parce
qu'il s'était enfermé dans une posture
politique il ne pouvait absolument pas
montrer qui s'était trompé et je pense
que ça explique aussi la la manière très
brutale aussi qui a été employée
aujourd'hui c'était on ne pouvait rien
montrer à l'avance
qu'on allait changer quelque chose parce
que ça aurait été finalement allé à
l'encontre du chef et de faiblesse voilà
par exemple si on avait construit des
hôpitaux si on avait si on avait
autorisé la production de vaccins
étranger avant qu'il y ait une
déclaration les gens se disent ça va
changer et donc du coup on aurait déjà
anticipé politiquement que sitting avait
quelque part Thor et donc on s'est
enfermé jusqu'au bout dans cette pour
des raisons purement politiques et on a
bien vu au mois de novembre que la
question économique ont repris le dessus
à un certain moment donné
et mais ça a été fait n'importe comment
parce que on se rend compte qu'on encore
une fois on est on est on a été dans une
voie sans issue on aurait pu tout à fait
d'ailleurs utilisez les armes d'un
régime
totalitaire pour éventuellement voilà
produire très rapidement des vaccins
mais on l'avait vu au début de par les
hôpitaux on l'avait vu au début de la
crise on a vu des hôpitaux se construire
en je sais plus oui mais 48 ou 72
ma première réaction quand quand il y a
eu la fin de la politique zéro coïdes ça
a été ça parce que moi je suis pas un
spécialiste de la Chine mais pourquoi
ils refont pas leurs hôpitaux aussi vite
et vous venez justement des raisons
politiques on sait enfermé jusqu'au bout
sur
l'impossibilité justement de mettre en
place ces mesures qui auraient facilité
une sortie en douceur en quelque sorte
de cette de cette crise du covid et
c'est tragique j'ai l'impression aussi
faire attention parce que la Chine on
les a toujours considérés un petit peu
rapidement je sais pas au départ quand
on se disait ils veulent apprendre un
petit peu nos technologies allez on leur
apprend et puis on se rend pas compte
qu'il nous pique nos technologies nos
savoir-faire et j'ai l'impression qu'on
a un peu ce défaut là aussi en se disant
alors pas nos invités qui connaissent
très très bien la Chine mais nous deux
peut-être en tout cas ce qui ce qui me
trame là dans la tête c'est une
interprétation parce qu'on voit les
failles tout d'un coup on voit les
failles d'une manière beaucoup plus
flagrante que ce qu'on voyait avant la
puissance économique tout ça on voit le
système autoritaire qui commence un
petit peu à se fissurer puisque les gens
n'en plus on voit ce qu'on a dit sur la
société des gens en ont ras-le-bol aussi
on voit que sur le plan de la
démographie ça marche pas aussi bien et
ça peut leur causer des gros problèmes
mais globalement ils ont quand même
beaucoup de ressources ne serait-ce que
dans leur pratique parce que le système
autoritaire je pense qu'il est pas non
plus terminé sur le plan industriel sur
le plan économique la façon dont tu les
utilises les ouvriers ne serait-ce que
sur des chantiers en Afrique sur la
façon de un peu
prendre un peu à la légère la sécurité
des hommes pas du tout de la même
manière que on le prend nous ça leur
donne quand même une certaine pouvoir et
on l'a bien vu au niveau géopolitique
aussi avec la guerre en Ukraine il reste
centrale ils ont ils jouent un peu le
rôle des arbitres entre l'Occident et la
Russie donc j'ai l'impression qu'il faut
pas enterrer en quelque sorte les
pratiques de la Chine et la façon et la
capacité surtout à se retourner et à
inventer moi je les vois très bien
imaginer un système social d'un coup du
chapeau parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
regardé chez nous ce qui se fait le
parangonnage si on veut rester français
plutôt que le benchmarking qui piocher
comme ils ont fait sur nos technologies
des choses qui pourraient incorporer
dans leur société je sais pas je rêve un
peu mais en tout cas ils l'ont fait pour
la partie logique
pour rester sur cette question de du
covid et du nombre de cas de covid qui a
évidemment flambé rapidement mais alors
le d'après le vice premier ministre
chinois le retour à la normale a été
aussi rapide il était en visite il est
en visite au Forum de Davos youway qui
annonce on va le lire que le temps
nécessaire pour atteindre le pic
épidémique et revenir à la normale a été
relativement rapide dans un certain sens
à dépassé nos anticipations Baptiste
falves là aussi est-ce qu'on quand il
parle d'un retour à la normale est-ce
qu'on est obligé de le croire alors dans
certaines villes le pic semble passer je
pense à Shanghai à Pékin là la
principale crainte c'est bien sûr tout
s'est afflux qu'on a vu d'ailleurs dans
le reportage de gens qui rentrent chez
eux plus vers le centre de la Chine oui
avec le double en chinois et le risque
de contamination de zone qu'il était de
façon très volatile juste ici après sur
les chiffres 60000 morts en quelques
jours oui c'est sûr que c'est plus
crédible que les 18 morts qui nous
avaient annoncé jusque là mais la
plupart des épidémiologistes ou des gens
qui se penchent sur le sur sur la
maladie et non absolument pas foi
confiance dans ses chiffres qui
forcément
sous-estime le nombre réel ça voilà
c'est évident maintenant juste je
voudrais faire un petit parallèle aussi
très rapide entre la crise du covid dont
on parle le confinement qui a duré
quasiment alors en tout cas le zéro
covid qui a duré 3 ans et la politique
de la natalité dont on parlait avant on
peut aussi être amené à penser que quand
vous avez des familles qui sont éclatées
pendant trois ans qui sont dispersés qui
peuvent pas se voir et le sentiment si
la sécurité est terrible que ça a créé
notamment en terme économique on peut
penser vraiment la nationalité ces trois
dernières années mais alors marie-josman
j'ai lu une de vos interviews vous
comparez cette crise vous dites le le
covid sera le Tchernobyl de la Chine
alors je veux bien que vous partagiez
l'analyse que vous faisiez dans cette
interview avec nos téléspectateurs parce
que c'est connaissez passionnant
pourquoi vous dites ça je dis ça parce
que les Chinois ont quand même découvert
que l'infaillible le site Jean Ping
c'était drôlement trompé donc à partir
du moment où une population cesse de
croire comme ça comme un seul homme au
chef leader et bien le doute s'installe
et à partir du moment où le doute
s'installe tout peut se fissurer je sais
ce qui s'était passé au moment de dans
les mois les années qui est après
86 la Suisse numéro sud du mur du Berlin
89 donc on peut penser que effectivement
si Jean Ping va être très ébranlé s'il
ne l'est pas déjà
on remarque par exemple que depuis qu'il
a été nommé à nouveau pour son troisième
mandat il n'a pas fait grand chose il a
fait quelques voyages à l'étranger il
est allé en Indonésie il est allé dans
les pays d'Asie centrale au moment de
l'incendie à euromshi qui a provoqué
toutes ses émeutes il n'a pas dit un mot
de compassion pour les
les victimes de cette incendie
aujourd'hui moi je pense que les morts
du covid se comptent par millions parmi
il n'a pas dit un mot alors je peux vous
faire le calcul en temps ordinaire il
meurt 300 pékinois par jour en ce moment
c'est 4500 dans les funérariums
c'est-à-dire qu'ils brûle 24 heures sur
24 dans les 90 funérariums bon de quoi
faire donc 4500 victimes
décès tous les jours donc moins les 300
ordinaires ça fait 4200 par jour et pour
le moment la queue pour aller aux
funérarium et d'un mois parce qu'ils
peuvent pas aller plus vite que la
musique évidemment donc on voit déjà
avec ça si vous multipliez ce 4300 à la
proportion du pays que on arrive à des
millions je peux pas vous dire combien
de millions j'ai pas si ce sera ce
rythme là partout mais j'observe aussi
quelque chose d'assez
les taux de solutions à Pékin et
Shanghai en ce moment on imagine avec
ces incinérations on sait que ça dégage
beaucoup de fumée et bien le taux de
pollution se maintient à airpocalypse à
deux heures du matin à 3h du matin à 4h
du matin
donc ça veut dire que c'est funérarium
tourne ça ils sont obligés parce que
déjà l'attente est d'un mois et si en
plus il tourne pas non-stop et ça
provoque une pollution parce qu'en ce
moment c'est pas l'industrie qui pollue
comme ça donc avec tout cela avec tous
les traumatismes qu'on vécu les Chinois
je pense que là il va y avoir un
terrible craquement il faut bien voir
que l'obtention du troisième mandat de
chez ginking c'est pas fait avec la
bienveillance de la population lorsque
sidine a annoncé qu'il allait garder son
poste les Chinois les intellectuels
chinois ont tous été dans un état de
dépression totale pourquoi parce que la
Chine est devenue la première République
en 2011 en 1911 de choisi et depuis 1911
les Chinois n'arrêtent pas d'essayer de
chercher une solution démocratique
sérieuse pour leur pays on arrive à 2023
on en est toujours là et en plus on se
paye un empereur qui est incompétent il
faut bien le dire il est incompétent
Jean-François Huchet à quel point ce 20e
Congrès a été en trompe l'oeil sur le
pouvoir de d'oxygène
je sais pas si on peut dire qu'il est
qu'il est en trompe l'oeil
[Musique]
il est pas fragilisé par la séquence
parce que c'est ce que moi je
sous-entends dans ma question peut-être
en attendant je pense que il a aussi
éliminé depuis maintenant le début de
son mandat 2012 il a fait en sorte de
placer des hommes de confiance partout
des groupes de travail qui qui opère sur
tous les domaines de économiques
militaires stratégiques
du pouvoir donc on peut quand même se
dire qu'il a aujourd'hui effectivement
un contrôle quasi total sur sur
l'appareil du parti et de répression et
de propagande ceci étant dit ce qui
guette derrière ça et on le voit au
détour de la crise du covid et d'autres
problèmes qui qui ont été mentionnés
c'est effectivement ce cette possibilité
du Brice c'est le comparer à ce qui se
passait sous tenseiaoping voire même au
delten shopping c'est qu'il y avait on
peut pas dire qu'il y avait loin de ça
une démocratie à l'intérieur du parti
mais il y avait une solution à
l'intérieur du parti et il y avait par
moment vous voyez des des différences
d'appréciation ensuite il y avait un
chef qui signait la fin de la partie
comment 89 mais vous voyez on avait la
possibilité d'avoir des rappels sur un
certain nombre de choses aujourd'hui ça
n'existe plus et donc les possibilités
qu'on avait connu aussi dans les années
60-70 où on a eu le pouvoir d'un seul
homme et on sait ce que ça a créé en
Chine et bien c'est ça peut se
multiplier ça peut se multiplier au
détour d'une crise avec Taïwan au détour
des États-Unis et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que c'est peut-être ce que
ce que la Chine doit craindre
c'est-à-dire une erreur humaine et une
appréciation de mauvaise appréciation de
la politique internationale ou des
questions économiques ou des questions
sociales ou politiques et je pense que
c'est ça peut-être aussi le danger qui
guette ce pouvoir hyper totalitaire
alors je reviens au chiffre de la
croissance on a va donner un peu plus
tôt dans l'émission mais la croissance
du pays chinois c'était c'est la plus
faible depuis près de 50 ans donc la
démographie c'est la première baisse
depuis 60 ans la croissance la plus
faible depuis 50 ans plus 3% en 2022
c'est la pire croissance vous voyez
depuis 1976 alors Émilie vous vous avez
choisi de vous pencher sur les relations
économiques entre entre l'Europe et la
Chine bah oui parce que si je vous
demande de trouver le point commun entre
des masques des métaux rares du lithium
des semi-conducteurs des aimants je
pense que vous me voyez venir puisque on
parle de Chine c'est la Chine justement
le point commun puisqu'elle fournit de
plus en plus la plupart de ces produits
et de ses matières la France est plus
globalement l'Europe depuis plusieurs
décennies sont devenus très très
dépendantes de la Chine pour ces
matériaux pour des produits pour des
composants de médicaments ces matières
qu'on dit des matières premières qu'on
dit critiques près de deux ressources
dites critiques sur trois arrivent
aujourd'hui de la Chine alors c'est quoi
les ressources critiques alors on les
appelle critiques car ce sont des
ressources qui sont indispensables pour
certaines filières stratégiques quand je
parle par exemple pour les éoliennes
c'est indispensable les terres rares bah
c'est pour nos petits téléphones
portables que nous aimons tant et ça
coûte plus cher en termes
environnemental de les rage c'est mieux
de les faire fabriquer en Chine plutôt
que de les amener chez nous et en cas
d'approvisionnement défaillant ou de
rupture d'approvisionnement chez nous ça
provoque des conséquences dramatiques
sur le plan économique et industriel un
spécialiste du sujet le journaliste
Guillaume Pitron a expliqué ça lors
d'une conférence de une conférence qui
était organisée le 14 mars
2022 on l'écoute puisque nous
transférons la production à d'autres
pays miniers et notamment la Chine qui
est le leader de la production des
métaux rares et critiques alors en fait
la Chine devient un grand producteur
majeur de ces matières premières qui
sont stratégiques elles deviennent si je
puis dire l'Arabie Saoudite des métaux
rares et critiques nous sommes dans une
situation de dépendance à la Chine bien
plus grave sur ces matières premières
que la dépendance au pétrole russe donc
on entend les mots assez fort en termes
de dépendance et puis c'est pas tout
parce que la Chine investit aussi
beaucoup en Europe à travers l'achat de
terres agricoles pour se nourrir
fabriquer elle investit aussi dans des
infrastructures comme les aéroports et
les ports évidemment on peut le rappeler
la crise covid a mis en avant cette
dépendance bien sûr je parlais des
masques tout à l'heure mais il y a aussi
la pénurie de substances pour fabriquer
les médicaments les kits de dépistage
les ventilateurs ont manqué de tout
parce que on manquait de tous les
produits qui venaient de la Chine la
guerre en Ukraine aussi en a rajouté une
couche parce que on se méfie de plus en
plus de ce partenaire commercial qui
nous des liens avec la Russie on veut se
passer de ces produits alors on termine
avec la réaction de l'Union européenne
la Réunion l'Union européenne alors au
départ en 2019 et le qualifié la Chine
de partenaires concurrents économique et
rival systémique en 2022 elle retient
surtout les deux derniers qualificatifs
on sera pas étonné concurrent et rival
et elle décide aussi de travailler plus
profondément sur la question de sa
souveraineté industrielle et économique
c'est le thème central en France et en
Europe relocalisation d'activités
industrielles diversification des
sources d'approvisionnement contraction
des métaux rares sur place en faisant
donc le pesant enfin l'équilibre entre
le risque environnemental et puis le
risque de dépendance mais c'est pas
simple parce que tous les membres de
l'Union européenne sont pas forcément
sur la même ligne là on vient de voir
les Allemands qui ont vendu une partie
du port de Hambourg à une société
chinoise donc on voit bien qu'on n'est
pas très carré sur sur le sens à donner
mais seul élément qu'on peut voir quand
même de positif au fur et à mesure de
ces crises c'est peut-être le temps de
la naïveté vis-à-vis de la Chine est
terminée révolue pour l'Union européenne
mais il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire bâtisse solvoz à quel point notre
diplomatie est dicté par notre
dépendance économique
allez encore beaucoup
Emmanuel Macron sur ce point ce qui
concerne en tout cas la Chine a quand
même donc depuis plusieurs années tenter
de renforcer l'indépendance stratégique
ce qu'il appelle de l'Union européenne
enfin et notamment les investissements à
risque venant sans le nommer mais venant
de Chine dans l'Union européenne mais il
y a encore une dépendance et puis de
toute façon on peut le voir aussi je
veux dire la vitesse à laquelle
s'empresse Emmanuel Macron et Olaf
scholls d'aller à Pékin rendre visite à
chidin alors manque de pot pour Emmanuel
Macron au live scholse la devancé
c'était il y a il y a un mois en allant
à Pékin à peine les frontières chinoises
ouvertes même avant la réouverture des
frontières chinoises Emmanuel Macron
devrait y aller en avril donc en tout
cas le le il y a pas de d'opposition
frontale comme on peut le voir avec les
États-Unis qui sont là vraiment dans une
vraie lutte de une vraie rivalité
historique et qui eux veulent mettre des
bâtons dans les roues à la Chine je
pense notamment aux exportations de ce
secteur clé que sont les
semi-conducteurs c'est vraiment le nerf
de la guerre aujourd'hui alors
Jean-François Huchet en parlera mieux
que moi mais les Etats-Unis qu'il y a
quelques mois ont décidé bien d'arrêter
d'exporter les fameuses puces
électroniques de très haut niveau à la
Chine pour que la Chine puisse pas
elle-même développer sa propre filière
de semi-conducteur c'est vraiment
quelque chose de
ultra stratégique on le retrouve dans
tous les appareils ultras sophistiqués
que ça soit dans le dans l'électronique
haut de gamme dans le militaire
également et ça on voit pas du tout un
tel front qui est mené par l'Union
européenne aujourd'hui qui veut
continuer de faire des affaires avec la
Chine il nous reste moins de autour de 3
minutes dans ce débat ça file trop vite
Jean-François Huchet je voudrais quand
même qu'on boucle là on s'est appuyé sur
le chiffre de la croissance de
2022 vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
que il y avait un alors il y a un lien
entre les trois thèmes qu'on brasse dans
cette dans ce débat évidemment la crise
covid évidemment la démographie et la
chute de la croissance la Chine elle a
des faiblesses
et elles sont accentuées par une faible
croissance pourquoi
je le disais Baptiste on a toujours la
théorie de l'éléphant qui fait du vélo
donc vous pédalez vite
vous gardez l'équilibre si vous
ralentissez et que vous pédalez plus
vous tombez
vous vous bien évidemment la Chine a
toujours eu des faiblesses économiques
on les a analysés depuis très très
longtemps sur son système bancaire sur
sur les rapports entre le centre et les
provinces sur la surproduction qu'on a
eu en Chine mais c'est facile de
résoudre des problèmes quand vous avez
10% de croissance ça l'est un peu moins
quand vous en avez 7 et ça devient
difficile quand vous avez deux ou trois
pour cent de croissance
par exemple vous voyez si vous avez des
mauvaises dettes dans le secteur
bancaire vous avez simplement à les
mettre de côté avec la croissance
économique de 10% en disant elles
existent plus et c'est ce qu'a fait la
Chine pendant longtemps aujourd'hui
encore une fois la Chine est confrontée
voilà de voir gérer des problèmes
économiques comme dans d'autres pays
économiques auxquels
c'est une c'est une voilà la Chine s'est
enrichie elle aborde aujourd'hui une
phase de sa croissance qui est difficile
et je partage aussi votre avis en disant
que ça va repartir au mois de mars il
faut s'attendre à ce que la croissance
chinoise atteignent un rythme naturel
qui sera plus 8% qui sera de 4 % mais ça
veut dire quand même que les choses vont
être beaucoup plus compliquées à partir
d'aujourd'hui en matière de gestion des
affaires économiques et donc il va pas
faire en sorte un dernier mot Marie
Holtzman puisqu'on parle du déclin alors
là on a été très économique mais vous
vous dites que c'est un régime finissant
je pense que c'est un régime finissant
oui parce que une dictature totalitaire
ne peut pas vivre à tout jamais
on chante beaucoup les les bienfaits du
gouvernement chinois pour la croissance
économique chinoise mais si on regarde
la diaspora chinoise ou qu'elle soit en
Indonésie en Thaïlande en Californie
elle fait des miracles donc c'est le
chinois qui fait la richesse de la Chine
et ce qui empêche la prospérité et le
bonheur réel des Chinois concrets c'est
une direction totalitaire il y a un
moment il faut que la Chine devienne un
état de droit elle est pour le moment un
état de non droit on ne peut pas croire
les chiffres on ne peut pas croire
la réalité des faits quand on gratte un
peu on voit que tous les grands
dirigeants chinois ont placé des
milliards à l'étranger on voit que tous
les grands 10 dirigeants chinois
envoient leurs enfants à l'étranger il y
a beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui
clochent dans ce pays donc il y a un
moment il faut que ça s'arrête on
termine là-dessus merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
bientôt sur sur public Senn